reject
okay it's working hello everyone so I
hope you had a great lunch because it
was really good so today I'll talk about
ampersand J's this is basically how
people call nan framing for non
framework a framework which you'll see
Norma why not first on just moment about
me I'm senior clean site engineer and I
seem extreme is a company made of
exclusively remote workers we don't have
any office anyone working in well let's
say in a one specific place and we
recently opened X lot which is fun to
educate it to just help people grow
learn new stuff we host various vers
events like meetups in Philippines -
let's say teach people Drupal we also
have a fund for open source projects so
if you have any idea for example to help
because we're specifically trying to
reach remote workers so if you have any
idea how to supper them and make their
life easier just let me know and we'll
make it happen so I am person Jess who
created it
so basically this team called and yet
and they had an idea if I guess most of
you heard about backbone which is
JavaScript framework but the issue is
that it was two monolithic it was just
one huge framework they tried to solve
your problems and if you wanted to use
only one part of this framework
you just couldn't because it was just
just one thing
so bunch of guys from this company try
to make the idea came with the idea how
to solve this and they decide to split
everything into really really small
pieces and give you everything to use
it's basically up to you which part to
use how you use it and it just tries to
solve
really very small problems and not make
you choose any of their solutions so
basically I joined their team few months
ago I guess two or three but we have
plenty of contributors all of them are
we are really thankful to them and if
you want to join just let us know there
is it's open source project for all so
you're more than welcome
I'd like to split this talk in two parts
first is a brief overview of ampersand
J's itself and then I'll move to our
philosophy how you do things and why I
did this in a specific way so this
ampersand as can really the higher model
or LC couples no framework a framework
for building otherwise just clipped
applications it's as as you can see from
the first view it's nothing more than
the smallest collections router's views
so and basically that's all nothing
unusual so my thing why is it different
I will try to display knit explain it in
a few words just bear with me for a
moment I will walk you through all the
basics so ampersand state this is basic
object of everything in the framework
it's based for every ol module that
you'll ever use currently there is a
object.observe in Atmos tube six that
everyone is waiting for well it's not
yet that that great it's pretty slow and
it's not it's not it can be used in
overall the browser's currently so what
they came with is it when you use
different data types you have three
choices properties which are data types
or different or basic objects which you
simply describe whether it's a string
number bullion diet it's up to you
whether it's acquired what are the
possible values all the stuff is
basically like schema for databases but
on the prefer decline
second is session session is this almost
the same like properties but it's it
meant to be used for only one session of
user so if you use to JSON or serialize
or something like this or we try to
store this model on server it won't be
passed because it's just session
variable and a another thing is the
derivative which are I've never seen
before I guess it's basically a property
that's dependent on other property and
it will react to changes in in this in
properties it depends on for example
here we have full name derivative which
depends on first name and last name and
every time either of those change there
if the property will be a Miss clear
calculated models because ampersand is
really modular each piece is made of
something else like a only ampersand
state and others on the router our state
level modules so here models are just
mix of ampersand state and ampersand
sink which give it ability to store
models on the server to fetch them to
say to destroy them and so on
collections there are a few few types of
collections we're in Backman forget we
had only one you know we had a few of
them first one is simple ampersand
collection it does nothing only stores
your models you know you know in one
group and only it also has a fuse
fefe other things like state as you said
because understand safety space for
everything so you can listen for changes
of everything on everything it's just up
to you and it also contains some
es5 metals like reduce filter map and so
on because ampersand is only a 9 higher
so you can use all s 5 metals so your
honor you go about this and other than
this ampersand collection only those
only some doesn't have anything
ampersand collection is made of amber
some collection is a collection sorry
ampersand collection itself and there is
a mixin which I will talk about with
underscore metals and you can use sub
collection for is it can create sub
collections of of previous collection
that will be automatically updated based
on your own your filters for example
here we have a base collection and on a
sub collection would favorite widgets
will see only data that contains
awesome true and comparator which is
just a way of sorting things you can add
filters remove filters choose whether to
you can also for example say that ok I
want the only models that have awesome
true but I want to listen for some other
properties and if this properties change
also update my sub collection and check
whether there's something here or or
maybe we should remove something animal
last one is impersonal Earth collection
which is a huge mixing of ampersand
collection and personalized mixing which
is which are just methods for
persisting here your data on server and
working with the API and the underscore
mixing switch gives you all the
abilities of underscore itself if used
there plenty of use there is not only
one like people are you see so ampersand
V is mix of ampersand state Dom bindings
and collection view collection is used
here only because we wanted to let
people render collections which is
really like a common come on task
without any of any other radishes and
the bindings are the way that you can
tell view which data from your model
should be should be used this is could
be compared to on go our bindings to a
data binding but I will explain why not
basically because it's not it's not the
way I think what worried me okay so here
is basically you give its template which
is string and it can only have
one root so one root element for for
template you can use either stringer
function but you don't have to recompile
your functions your templates or place
data in it and so on I think there are
data hooks which will be used for for
data bindings I will talk about and
include listen for example for events
and some additional thing for this view
is that can you can register a sub views
before which was a pretty calm coming
think you want if you do in for example
backbone but won't able to and
collection view is iterative wire to
create single view inside the inside the
container which is also contained in
ampersand do you but maybe you have a
use case to render collection only you
know ampersand views feature it's
something like you can create a region
it's it's normal culture from mario net
exactly you can create a region which
you can use to swap views inside many
for example you can have a button with
tabs or something like this and you can
say that after I click this button let's
switch this view and place new things
inside and it will automatically
register or all your events destroy all
the elements clear memory and all stuff
it's made of ampersand you as base plus
it has just a few simple ways a few
simple functions in can specify here how
to how to hide this view how to show
this video and whether you want to wait
for before it's gone the first the first
view are not super example you can use
this to animate those views or set new
title or I know maybe scroll top as you
can see form you this thing that I
really really like handling forms is
it's hard it's hard basically it's it's
really hard and the way we try to solve
this is you can create a huge contains
all the inputs it's it doesn't really
care what inputs you'll place in there
but it will handle all the all the data
a validation if you will test
whether you can send send it over to the
server you can reach the call button and
all this stuff
it also check whether to show error
messages for you just just just like
that you don't have to specify anything
and there are a few few inputs that you
can you can choose on there's input view
which is a simple simple input you just
describe its label its name validation
rules and so on our input which is
basically the same well as input but it
allows you to create multiple instances
if you just want to get RI of values
from from for example as we had with the
example of adding shipping costs
this is exactly the same use case where
you can just add new weights of other
package for example select view which
will create select for you check box
view and you can place all of them
inside the form view and you will just
they will all just play together it's up
to you which one you choose and we are
now on view bindings this what to talk
about because this thing that it's hard
to get it right
don't - uh usually well there is a of
course that there is rocked right now
which only change the things that the
change itself it doesn't render a whole
view but what we just suffer alone is we
have this issue recently about how do
you tell HTML that it should be bind a
bound in specific place so until now we
use the rolls attribute on HTML elements
and someone pointed out that this kind
of exhibition because there are various
Aria roles which are used as a role and
if you keep to use those roles you'll
eventually use role which is reserved
for Aria and you will miss P break X
ability for your for your users so
there's a huge debate
became the ideas like use
the data is data bind data hook letter
action
rel attribute name attribute classes is
like few a few weeks long but in the end
we came we finished with a data hook so
it's it's a way how we use this in HTML
and we have a few few bindings I think
is you can tell which things from model
to use and in which place interview
itself so text binding is using a text
from from the model itself to be placed
in the view class is using a class in
attribute attribute is mapping you just
say which attribute you want to match
with which value from model and it will
just update value are four inputs
boolean plus and boolean attributes are
just your interpolated value of modulus
whether it will return true or false it
will swap those classes or attributes
and toggle and switch are basically the
same but for visibility so if you're for
example model that visible is true they
will be visible if not they will just be
hidden and innerhtml is placing HTML
itself inside inside the element the
thing that i forget to forget it all
about is that in models in an inside
because thanks to registering called all
the data types because if we specify
data type we as I said we create schema
of some kind of some kind of and we are
able to lock the schema by passing allow
our values our values of luck and thanks
to this we are able to listen we're able
to let's say mimic object.observe
because we can use object defined
property which is from its es5 not es6
and we can use either model that age for
example to set this age or model that
set
as a function and no matter which we
will choose it will always trigger
change value because it will be
registering or properties not writing
then is inside an object itself in a
router it's all same router it will just
register your your routes and trigger
functions according T to route your
currently now it will handle back baton
Fe story you can navigate you can
redirect your your users and see and
this is the fun part
I like the most are the mixing so
because the ampersand is so modular you
can we have amber sound plus x10 which
is um which is module for creating other
modules let's let's call it this way
this basically export the function that
lets you chain prototypes of your
subclasses effectivity can create one
small functionality that will mix into
other things for example let's say you
have model which you really like but
you're not using Earth API but real
communication so instead of using a
model which is made of a personal state
and the upper side sink you can use
ampersand State and create your own for
example ampersand real time I think
something like this and you can mix them
and you'll get the same thing as
ampersand model but with a real time
communication and you don't have the
polite
it's very pollute ampersand ampersand
model you can use it in a in the same
way as you did before because basically
you didn't modify the old version and
current mix is our collection res mixes
as I said before it contains all the
persisting functions underscore mixing
with all the own functionality of
underscore don't think which is created
about Phillip it led to this bind
manually automatically a history all the
all the data not by using data hoops and
so on but all double
rockets and it will just render render
the view on its own and see people so
recently started to work on ampersand
react mix in which you can also also
create it's just up to you you can is I
know Amber's on flux mixing or something
like this it's just I feel because you
can create anything from this and last
button please ampersand CLI it's
addition one thing that should help you
create am person apps if you ever use
your money you should probably be
familiar with uh with the concept it
lets you start a new application you can
say name of the application which API
you want to use because we currently
support happy and and Express apps it
will create structure for you and so on
all the configurations you have few
configuration file which you can
configure all your application in 5 mins
you can burn rate form views and models
you know just type ampersand Jen form
and you get your four simple input view
or something like this you can generate
models from JSON if you have already
pre-created API and it's pretty it
wasn't pretty big use no the money will
create all those models you can
basically just send a request get all
the JSON from the server and just place
it in your terminal just just pipe it to
your own personal generator and it will
create Model Model from from this API
and it will offers handle all the data
types it will detect whether it's a
number or boolean or R and so on and it
can occur in form for most if you for
example gonna write model let's say you
have IP I with create user and in a
responsive from create user you get all
the same values as confirmation you can
get this response create create models
using this generator and then use the
same model to create form for creating
your user for example so it's too easy
steps and you have or the create form
and you can configure the code when you
create your application you will get
ampersand RC which you where you can
specify all the default templates all
puffs if you don't do forgetting to
change change something and so on so
this was about amber Sun and now why I
created this and what's her philosophy
Stefan talke Stefan's talk feels really
good because he said we should scratch
or on each and I totally I'm just I
agree in it all because I said to build
great products he want to use them
yourself first so what do you want it it
is there are always different projects
with the different requirements so what
you want to have is just base for let's
say base base stuff base code base that
you want to use and you want only those
small those small parts those small
blocks it's like UNIX tools of you say
says that you should do only one thing
and one thing well this is exactly the
same if you want to use some other block
for the same for the same task you can
do this it's up to you and Henry Carr
who I guess was first creator of
ampersand that the first person who
started this cell yesterday
optimized for change it's the only
constant and I wouldn't say better
because he's basically right he's just
right nothing is nothing nothing is
constant
other than change because everything
will change sooner or later and it's not
about solving a problem is how we
approach it is if you solve a problem
once you are more than ensure that you
will have a slightly different but
Indian the same problems in in your life
as you go on so you had the thing about
the help you think about how you solve
this problem how we approach those
problem not how you solve them because
every solution will be probably
different you have to know the way of
solving those and it's easier to learn
only things you need you know if you get
one huge framework like learning curve
big frame work is like you are here you
know nothing and to go to the top it's
like even straight straight to the top
you know you have to know everything to
even start with basic application where
if you come to the project and you're
asked to fix small bug or something like
this and you know where this bug is but
you know how it's how it works with
other parts if we fuse amber sound you
don't have to know these parts because
this one module which is responsible for
this and if you know it's API which is
probably really really small you can fix
this problem you can change it you can
modify its it's it's not that hard and
now everything is separate come on Jess
model we use browserify for everything
you can use webpack if you want it's up
to you but we keep the same same way for
some same way of doing things for every
module and this way we are constant and
we don't have any surprises if
everything changes it's easy to reuse
our code we can expertly require all the
things
everything is first and NPM it allows us
to create applications so really quick
it's like rapid prototyping if someone
say this way
everything should be focused at and we
are still working on this there are few
pieces that that are not tested but we
will get there and now every every small
module in a person has its own github
repository everything and what this lets
you do is we also had this dissing did
this issue
well nothing she did this case it's
someone came in he wanted to modify one
for small modules and everything had to
do was just fork it change it change
URLs in package a status that's all and
if you for example if you change a model
and something was dependent on it there
is a no problem because you basically
can link them in package JSON and they
all upgrade like like this like you know
nothing happened everything has separate
issues so let's say
have huge team and have 30 40 maybe
modules you can with me that is hard to
maintain them all so what's not good
idea is to separate those small modules
between let's say pairs of people who
can maintain those and thanks to a
separation of the other issues you can
say you can keep saying because if you
see two hundred issues it's not the best
view but if yours if you have them
separated it's much much easier to
handle them and everything is separate
life if you have something that's really
a huge monolithic
it's hard to change things there it's
like working with legacy code you change
one thing and everything can break like
like this you never know why and if you
use do small modules you can basically
bump version every patch you can just
pass version publish it to NPM and
everything everyone is happy because
they simply got the feedback they
instantly get the newer and better
version of this I mean if you if you
would like to do this in the same way
with a with a huge huge player MOOC I
guess you'd run out of version numbers
if you keep two semantic versioning
similar later and as I said everything
do one thing and do it well and I guess
that everyone should keep through those
words because we can see more and more
libraries and frameworks that are so
huge and so difficult to grasp that it's
just too hard for new developers to come
to your project or even to adjust script
word because it's just overwhelming when
they see so much tools so much remote so
much libraries they just don't know
where to put their hands in and last
leverage existing solutions and not
driven the wheel we have things like
Bower and PM come on Jas require if you
have if you have a some kind of problem
probably any kind of problem there is
huge chance that already someone solve
this problem and it's available on NPM
and because we are using browserify and
common J's you can just grab the
solution placing in your cold and he'll
work just like it and because of this we
created this page called tools and
percentages which is H we don't already
chosen by by us solutions for for common
problems if you have something there's
of course suggestion suggest a module
link you can let us know when we will
place this on in this index and this all
had say we are always grateful for all
the contributions if you want to use
ampersand just go to ampersand J is calm
if you want to be a part of a team just
let us know there is huge room for
improvements and we have plenty of space
for new team members you are more than
welcome thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
reject